für die jährliche redezulage der Union
zu begrüßen
in den letzten Jahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Intelligenz ihr Leben beeinflussen
in den nächsten Jahren einen Job ein
Haus zu finden
die nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg von einer
besseren
[Musik]
Zukunft
Menschen zusammenarbeiten um gemeinsam
mit Frieden zu leben
in Europa als die Antwort auf die
Herausforderungen der damaligen
Generation
aus der neuen Generation sprechen
[Musik]
etwas zu gestalten
historischen Herausforderungen erstellen
muss
wir gemeinsam angehen müssen das with
earning the trust of Europeans to deal
with beginnt
und Europäer verdienen
niemals in den kommen wir die Aufgaben
zu Ende bringen
das Haus ich möchte dieses rollenden
deswegen führen
Transformationen denken die diese Union
today aber schauen Sie nun wo
europäischen
die Ukraine unterstützen
Europe
getragen
und Reformen im Umfang von 800
Milliarden Euro kombiniert
für heute
wir haben das Fundament für eine
gesundheitsunion kommen
kritischen Bereichen wie Energie mit
Chips und Rohstoffe
ich möchte Ihnen auch für die
bahnbrechende Arbeit denken
geleistet haben also women
viele gedacht haben
die Richtlinie überfahren bzw
sein Geld verdient gesetzlich
der ist nur Moment es gibt kein Einzel
Moment warum eine Frau bei gleicher
Arbeit
aber unsere Arbeit getan
zu bekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
2019 vorgelegt habe together live
gemeinsam haben wir die Zeit was in
Europa das ist alles schaffen kann
zusammenhalten lassen Sie uns heute
handeln und für morgen bereit zu sein
meine Damen und Herren
vor 4 Jahren
der historischen Herausforderung
gestaltet
und der diesjährige Sommer
verzeichnet wurde hatten sie
Dringlichkeit
Bulgarien und überall in unserer Union
dies ist die Realität eines Planeten der
kocht
jo Pinguin Deal
wurde aus dieser Notwendigkeit
herausgebrochen unseren Planeten zu
schützen
du preserve auf YouTube
zu bewahren
Perspektive haben wir mit dem Gesetz
Früchte trägt
Industrie
bereit ist diesen Übergang
voranzubringen
das Modernisierung
gehen können
ist die Zahlen Zauberer stahlfabriken
von 0
[Musik]
gesprungenen Energie betrieben wird das
ist das ist die Krankheit to climate
change
the Europe
[Applaus]
wir müssen diese Arbeit zu Ende bringen
Ökosystem Entwickeln
von this Mann und wir fangen Energie
ist eine europäische Erfolgsgeschichte
meine einzigartigen Kombination von
herausfordern
wir ein Paket für die Windkraft in
Europa vorlegen
wir werden die genehmungsverfahren
[Applaus]
ehrgeizig wir halten an unserer
Wachstumsstrategie fest und wir werden
uns immer für einen fairen und gerechten
Übergang starten for future
Generationen sie sollen leben können und
dann wäre das Angebot an alle betreiben
dass niemand zurückgelassen wird
chinesischen Konkurrenten Teilnehmer
keniaunternehmen mussten Insolvenz
anmelden promishing Talents
Ausland um dort ihr Glück zu versuchen
das ist deshalb ist gerne
für die Weltwirtschaft ist so important
because the facts hat Einfluss auf
unsere
Lebenshilfen
deshalb müssen wir uns über die Risiken
denen wir gegenüber stehen absolut im
Klaren sein take the electric Remix nur
den elektrofahrzeugsektor
Klinik haben
Elektroautos überschwand an der Preis
ist kein Preis dieser Auto bei riesige
staatliche Subventionen künstlich
Gedicht ist es dorthin
verzerrt wie du not excep this is
Thorsten
von ihnen akzeptieren
heute mitteilen Wetter Kommission eine
subventionsuntersuchung zu
Elektrofahrzeugen aus China
[Applaus]
wir müssen uns gegen unfaire
praktikulieren
nach China offen zu halten
können und müssen die risk riesige
minimieren
später in diesem Jahr sein
meine Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
in der Europäischen Union
sind wir stolz auf unsere kulturelle
Vielfalt
wir sind das Europa der Region
mit einer ganz besonderen Vielfalt dann
sprachen Musik Kunst Tradition
Handwerk kulinarischen Köstlichkeiten
wir sind auf das Europa eine
einzigartigen biologischen Vielfalt
etwa 6.500 Arten kommen nur
allein in Europa vor nirgendwo anders
auf der Welt
im Norden Europas liegt das
Weltnaturerbe Wattenmeer ein
einzigartiger Lebensraum der seltenen
Tier- und Pflanzenarten der Ihnen eine
Heimat bietet und für Millionen von
Zugvögeln überlebenswichtig
und mit der Ostsee haben wir das größte
Brackwassermeer der Welt nach Süden
schließen sich europäische Tiefebenen an
die von großen Mooren und Feuchtgebieten
geprägt waren und sind
diese Regionen sind wichtige Verbündete
gegen das Fortschreiten des Klimawandels
geschützte Moore und Feuchtgebiete
binden große Mengen an Treibhausgasen
sichern nationale Wasserkreisläufe
regionale Wasserkreisläufe und
beheimaten eine
einzigartige Biodiversität
Europas waldreich
von mächtigen Nadelwäldern im Norden und
Osten über die letzten Urwälder von
Eichen und buchenden Mitteleuropa
bis hin zu den Korkeichenwäldern
Südeuropas die von alle diese Wälder für
uns nicht zu ersetzen der Güter und
Leistungen
sie binden Kohlenstoff
sie liefern Holz und andere Produkte
sie erzeugen fruchtbare Böden Filtern
Luft und Wasser
Biodiversität und Ökosystemleistungen
sind für alle Menschen in Europa
überlebensnotwendig
der Verlust dieser Natur
zerstört nicht nur die Lebensgrundlage
sondern auch das Heimatgefühl von
Menschen
wir müssen sie schützen
[Applaus]
und gleichzeitig muss auch die Sicherung
unserer Lebensmittelversorgung mit und
in der Natur
Aufgabe sein und bleiben
ich möchte heute unseren Landwirten
meine Anerkennung aussprechen
[Applaus]
meine Anerkennung und mein Dank dafür
dass sie uns Tag für Tag mit
Lebensmitteln versorgen
gesunde Lebensmittel für uns in Europa
ist diese Aufgabe der Landwirtschaft die
Grundlage der Agrarpolitik und auf die
Unabhängigkeit in der
Lebensmittelversorgung ist uns wichtig
das leisten unsere Landwirte
das ist nicht selbstverständlich
denn die Folgen der russischen
Aggression gegen die Ukraine der
Klimawandel mit dürren Waldbränden und
Überflutungen
aber auch neue Verpflichtungen
prägen zunehmend die Arbeit der
Landwirte und ihre Einkommenssituation
wir müssen dem Rechnung tragen
viele setzen sich schon heute für eine
nachhaltigere Landwirtschaft ein
wir müssen zusammen mit den Menschen in
der Landwirtschaft diese neuen
Herausforderungen bewältigen nur so
können wir unsere
Lebensmittelsicherheit auch in Zukunft
absichern
das heißt wir brauchen mehr Dialog
und weniger Polarisierung und aus diesem
Grund möchten wir einen strategischen
Dialog zur Zukunft der Landwirtschaft in
der Europäischen Union starten denn ich
bin und bleibe davon überzeugt das
Landwirtschaft und Naturschutz zusammen
gehen können beides ist wichtig
[Applaus]
angesichts der wirtschaftlich äußerst
schwierigen Zeiten die wir durchleben
sind die
Arbeitskräfte Mangel die Inflation
und die Rahmenbedingungen für
Unternehmen
wir haben die Anfänge der globalen
Pandemie nicht vergessen
Arbeitslosigkeit im Spiel von 1930 wir
haben sie alle schon bestraft
Europe
40 Millionen Arbeitszeit gerettet ist
war die soziale Marktwirtschaft Europas
in Aktion und wir können stolz auf sie
sein
economic Engine thanks to next
generation den Wirtschaftsmotor sofort
wieder angeworfen die Ergebnisse sind
nun sichtbar Europa
Menschen sind weder in Arbeit noch in
Schule oder Ausbildung
ihre Träume müssen warten muss
verursacht nicht nur viel Gesundheit
es ist auch eines der größten
Hindernisse für unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
beim Arbeitskräftemangel bremst
Innovationsfähigkeit
vor allem für junge Menschen
technologischen gesellschaftlichen und
demografischen wandeln
vorbei on the
expertisepartner spricht der Unternehmen
und Gewerkschaften zurückgreifen musst
40 Jahren since
weil du chef meeting in weil durch das
Interesse einberufen auf Europe
die Union von heute gefreut und dadurch
Millionen von Menschen und Wohlstand
in der heutigen Welt die sich schneller
wandelt dass sie zuvor kommt den
sozialen bei der Gestaltung unser
Zukunft
gemeinsam müssen wir die Herausforderung
für den Arbeitsmarkt in den Bildschirm
vom Fach und Arbeitskräftemangel bis hin
zu dem neuen Herausforderungen
diesen Grund werden wir nächstes Jahr
gemeinsam mit der belgischen
Präsidentschaft in Deutschland ja erneut
den Sozialpartnern
[Musik]
Europas wird mit und von unseren
Sozialpartnern aufgebaut ist
einige Zeit brauchen wird bisher gehört
wir müssen fast Ding ziehen der EZB
liegen wird gute Nachricht ist dass die
Energiepreise
auf europäischer Ebene zurückgehen wir
haben nichts vergessen
hat
unsere energievorratinnen Winter
geschlossen
Erneuerbare Energien investieren wenn
die Umstellung auf saubere Technologien
darzutreiben für kritische Masse Europas
dazu genutzt die Preise zu senken und
unsere Versorgung
mehr als 300 Euro krummigerwattstunde
dieses Erfolgsmodell in anderen
Bereichen
können
oder zum Beispiel sauberem Wasserstoff
die dritte
herausnehmen ihre
Tätigkeiten Komplexität
oder sie werden durch langwierige
Verfahren
der mir direkt gestaltet
[Applaus]
vor welchen Herausforderungen sie
tagtäglich stehen
wir unterziehen
einem
wettbewerbsfähigkeitscheck ab der von
uns unabhängigen und im kommenden Monat
werden
Verringerung der Meldepflichten auf
europäischer Ebene um 25%
[Applaus]
und wir benötigen Ihre Unterstützung
denn dies ist ein gemeinsames
Unterfangen aller europäischen
match the trend auch mit den
Mitgliedstaaten zusammenarbeiten um auf
nationaler Ebene 25% Ziel zu erreichen
es ist an der Zeit den Unternehmen in
Europa ihre Tätigkeiten zu erleichtern
diese europäische Industriepolitik auch
eine gemeinsame europäische Finanzierung
aus diesem Grund haben wir im
Rahmenbedingungen
unseres Hauses
Plattform
können
und steuern und in allen Bereichen
Informatik
Technologien
unsere Unternehmen benötigen
über unseren Haushaltsvorschlag zu
erzielen und ich weiß dass ich auf
dieses Haus sehen kann
[Applaus]
die auch auf die gezielte Politik
anderer Länder zurückzukommen
für Europa so wichtig ist die
wirtschaftliche Sicherung zu erhöhen
durch Minderung von Risiken
dass dieses Konzept bei unseren
wichtigen Partner breite Zustimmung
gestoßen ist von Australien und
Vereinigten Staaten und viele andere
Länder der weltweit wollen
zusammenarbeiten
hängen viele von ihnen alles Afrika
Verarbeitung meiner Finanzierung
aufbauen in stead of
Ressourcen ins Ausland zu verschüssen
intelligente Handel schafft gute
Arbeitsplätze und Wohlstand
[Applaus]
Führung zu gehen wir müssen deshalb
weiter in die Zukunft blicken und
dagegen wie wir dabei wettbewerblich
bleiben
und aus diesem Grunde Mario ich Mario
Wirtschaftsexperten Europas
der europäischen wettbewerbung denn
Europa wird tun was immer nötig ist und
seinen Wettbewerbsvorteil zu erhalten
making business and life easy I have
der Wirtschaft bessere Möglichkeiten
geben
für digitale Projekte bei next
generation
Detail
und ihr verkehrt
hat Europa eine Vorreiterrolle beim
Umgang mit den Risiken geboren
für den Austausch von Wissenschaft dafür
den geistigen Horizont zu erarbeitet und
die Menschen zusammenzubringen und das
ist auch nach wie vor aber
und Risiken für den Schutz unserer
privaten
zu einem Vertrauen und manchmal auch zu
einer Verletzung der Grundrechte von
Menschen
Europa zum weltweiten Vorreiter für die
Bürgerrechte in der digitalen
schaffen einen sicheren digitalen Raum
in dem die Grundrechte geschützt sind
klare Verantwortlichkeiten der
Unternehmen dies ist eine historische
Errungenschaft und ich glaube wir
sollten stolz darauf
das gleiche sollte für die künstliche
Intelligenz
Gesundheitsversicherung verbessern die
Produktivität steigern
wir brauchen sie aber wir sollten auch
nicht die durchaus real,-
von ihren Erfindern angenommen
in
verantwortungs-
zu einem neuen globalen Rahmen für KI
vorgeben
[Musik]
und gelenkte
menschenzentrierte
transparenzischen
Intelligenz vorgelegt das weltweit erste
umfassende Innovation
gesehen habe
unermüdliche Arbeit an diesem
richtungsweisenden
Möglichkeiten verabschieden und umsetzen
zusammen tun um einen Ansatz für das
Verständnis der Auswirkungen KI in
unsere Gesellschaft zu gewährleisten
dass der Politik die neuesten
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnis zur
Verfügung haben ich glaube wir brauchen
ein ähnliches für die KI benefits über
die riesigen und ihre Nutzen für die
Menschheit also
Technologie
Fachleute müssen wir weltweit haben
weil weit abgestimmt Handeln on the work
Downloader Arbeit des Hiroshima
Prozesses und anderen
verantwortungsvolle Steuerung von
Innovation
in der vergangenen Jahren in Europa
ten wir all diese Arbeiten
zusammenführen für globale mindestens
eine sichere und ich liebe Nutzung das
haben die Menschen in Europa verdient
unser Team Europa Konzept hatte nur
appetitlich Strate
und
geschlossenen Verluste an Menschen leben
nach den heftigen Überschwemmungen und
dem Erdbeben Europa
in jeder erdenklichen Weise zu helfen
ärmsten Regionen deren Bevölkerung aber
am schnellsten Weg
von militärbürsten
zum Beispiel und schlägt gleich capital
und die Region ist fruchtbarer Boden für
zunehmenden Terrorismus geworden
unmittelbar unsere Sicherheit und unsere
Wohlstand wir müssen also Afrika
gegenüber ebenso an einem Strang ziehen
uns auf die Zusammenarbeit mit
rechtmäßigen Regierung und regionalen
organisationschaften die sich mit Fragen
beschäftigt die für Europa und Afrika
Kaiser von Interesse sind deshalb werden
wir im Verbund mit dem hohen verkehrte
Hamburg ein neues Strategiekonzept der
Arbeiten dass wir
EU Afrika Gipfel
Histor Abgeordnete wir stehen vor einer
historischen Frisuren
umfassenden Krieg gegen die Grund der
un-karte
sie fürchten Seiten dass sie in einer
Gesetzlosen Welt das gleiche Schicksale
Ukraine
zurückzukehren mit dem versuchskalender
wieder dazwischen zu isolieren empfinden
die regelbasierte Atmosphäre gestalten
und zu mir
verteilungsgerechtigkeiten
zusammenarbeiten um ihre Bande zu
knüpfen und Europas
transparenter nachhaltiger und
wirtschaftlich attraktiver
Projekt unsere Generation unterzeichnet
Verbindung sein
läuft und Europa
einer grünen
wasserstoffpersonen Energie zwischen
Asien und Europa
innovativsten digitalen Ökosystem der
Welt miteinander zu bezahlen
[Musik]
schneller kürzen
davon brauchen wir mehr
[Applaus]
zu einer digitalen Wirtschaft für den
Weg gehen
Investitionen in der Wirtschaft unserer
Partner
Wohlstand und Sicherheit in einer sich
raschwandelnden meine Damen und Herren
Abgeordnete Chuck so Tarifvertrag werden
menschlich durch Konflikte Klimawandel
populationalität
Überzeugung dass Migration gesteuert
werden muss
das erfordert Geduld diese Forderungen
in Abstimmung mit unseren Partner
Geschlossenheit innerhalb unserer
Partner
Protektion die Person und dem Schutz der
Menschen unsere Souveränität zwischen
Souveränität und Solidarität
Interesse zwischen Sicherheit und
Menschlichkeit nun
haben allen Mitgliedstaaten
mit allen Migration
praktische Lösungen umgesetzt
schnell
geschlossen
zusammengearbeitet und irreguläre
zehnjährige sie sind mit Tunesien
eine Partnerschaft
skompetenz
und wir wollen
mit anderen Ländern
insbesondere Bulgarien und Rumänien
danken
gutem Beispiel vorangegangen sind indem
sie auf bewährte Verfahren im Bereich
Asien und mein Rückführung verwiesen
egal und Rumänien sind teil und lassen
wir sie also endlich herein ohne
weiteren Verzug
Medien
der Migration auf der Überzeugung dass
eine Einigung greifbarer Nähe liegt noch
nie
einer Verständigung
Parlament und Rat haben
einmalige Gelegenheit ist so beschließen
dass Europa die Migration
und viele
Steuern kann bringen wir die Arbeiten
zum Abschluss
[Applaus]
dass die Migration ständiger
Aufmerksamkeit erfordert und das geht
insbesondere für den Kampf gegen die
Schlepper desperate
verzweifelte Menschen lehren
Versprechungen sie schicken sie über
tödliche Routen durch die Wüste oder
nicht die geboten auf offenem Meer die
Fantasie keine Grenzen aber unsere
Gesetzgebung sind über 20 Jahre alt und
muss dringend aktualisiert werden
neue Rechtsvorschriften und eine neue
Struktur wir brauchen eine strengere
Anwendung des Gesetzes strafrechtliche
Verfolgung und mehr Befugnisse für
unsere Agenturen
European Zusammenarbeit nur so können
wir in dieser Welt einheim vorbeikommen
deshalb plant die Kommission eine
internationale Konferenz zur Bekämpfung
des Menschenhandels es ist an der Zeit
und verbrecherischen Geschäft und Ende
zubereiten
on the day an dem Tag mein Russian Tanks
die russischen Panzer über die Grenze in
die Ukraine rollten würde
sie sagte
weil wir zu Hause sind
die Ukraine sagte er explant also
erklärt
Europa
ihr zu Hause war
zu Hause wo wir einander vertrauen
konnten ihre Mitmenschen in Europa
[Musik]
Generation und hat unermüdlich für die
Gerechtigkeit ein One wollt ihr Sohn in
Sicherheit war
in die ukrainischen
Kriegsverbrechen zu Dokumentieren
von einer russischen Rakete getötet
während sie bei einem Abendessen mit
anderen Menschen sie ist Opfer eines
russischen Kriegsverbrechens geworden
einer davon war
ein Schriftsteller Kollege aus Kolumbien
hespaart Kampagnen
um die Menschen in Lateinamerika über
den russischen Überfall und die Angriffe
auf die Zivilbevölkerung
eingefallen dass er selbst zum Ziel
werden könnte später sagte er dass er
nicht wüsste warum er noch am Leben und
sie gestorben sein Bad Nauheim
um die Erinnerung an sie zu bewahren und
diesen Krieg zu beenden und es ist mir
eine Ehre
und ich möchte Ihnen danken
und ich möchte sie wissen lassen
[Applaus]
Ukraine
solange sie nötig seit Beginn des
Krieges haben vier Millionen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine in unserer
Union Zuflucht gefunden und ich möchte
Ihnen sagen dass sie heute noch genauso
gekommen sind
dafür gesorgt dass Sie Zugang zu
Wohnraum Gesundheitsdienst in dem
Arbeitsmarkt und viel mehr
meine Damen und Herren Abgeordneter
stellte sich Europa dem Gebot der Stunde
Verlängerung des vorübergehenden
Schutzes für die Ukrainerinnen in der EU
vorgeschlagen hat vorschlagen wird
unsere Unterstützung
[Applaus]
12 Milliarden Euro für die zahlungs-
und Krankenhäuser Schulen und andere
Dienste am Laufen zu Hause und mit
unserem Vorschlag steigern wir die
emotionsproduktion um den unmittelbaren
Bedarf der Ukraine zu decken doch wir
schauen weiter
die Bewilligung von weiteren 50
Milliarden Euro für jeden Investitionen
von Westen über vier Jahre
beitragen zu ihrem Wiederaufbau als
modernes und blühen das Land und diese
Zukunft ist deutlich abzusehen
dieses Haus hat es laut in deutlich
ausgesprochen die Zukunft der Ukraine
die Zukunft des Balkans liegt in unserer
Union die Zukunft
[Applaus]
für viele Menschen in Georgien ist
meine Damen und Herren
zu Beginn meiner Freunde
wie sich Europa seiner historischen
Aufgabe stand
und diese Aufgabe ist unsere Union zu
vollenden
wir versuchen sich andere Länder nach
und nach unter dem Nagel zu reißen
können wir es uns nicht leisten und die
europäischen Freunde im Stich zu lassen
in einer Welt in der Größe und
das ganz klar im
strategischen Interesse Europas die
Union zu finden
was auf dem Spiel stehen
eine Vision für eine erfolgreiche
Erweiterung
mit über 500 Millionen Menschen die in
einer freien demokratischen und
blühenden Gemeinschaft der Union
complete eine vollendete und Julian der
junge Menschen in Freiheit leben
Studierenden
Demokratien in denen die justizist
unabhängig ist
Opposition respektiert wird und
Journalisten und Journalisten
unsere Union bilden werden in den
heutigen wie auch künftigen
[Applaus]
Priorität wir arbeiten jetzt mit dem
Mitgliedsstaaten Mengen zusammen und
Fortschritte und Bedenken feststellen
wir sprechen für das kommende Jahr
Empfehlungen
vor diesem Haus und den nationalen
Parlament gewählt sind es wurde der
Dialog zwischen den Mitgliedstaaten
ermöglicht und es bringt Ergebnisse ich
denke
dasselbe auch für künftige
Mitgliedstaaten möglich
ganz besonders Bienen mitteilen zu
können dass wir die Berichte über die
rechtschreiblichkeit jenen
Beitrittsländern zugänglich machen die
Weiterfahrt aufnehmen
Mitgliedstaaten auf Augenhöhe
und bei ihren reformbetüren
und es wird sichergestellt dass
in einer Union der allgemeinen Freiheit
Rechte und Werte liegt
[Applaus]
Parlament Mitgliedstaaten Kommission
interest danke liegt in unser aller
Interesse
Erweiterung vor 20 Jahren
die europäische willkommensgröße
in den 20 Jahren dieser vergangenen sind
haben wir eine wirtschaftliche
erfolgsstörung erlebt die das Leben von
Millionen Menschen verbessert hat
dass wir uns auf die nächste europäische
Willkommensfeier und die nächsten
wirtschaftlichen Erfolgsgeschichten
freuen wir wissen dass dieser Weg nicht
einfach ist ein Beitritt im Leistung und
die Kommission wird diesen grundsätzlich
stets verteidigen es erfordert und
Führungsstärke
aber schon jetzt gibt es viele Vorteile
großen Schritte gesehen die die Ukraine
bereits gemacht hat nachdem er der
Kandidaten verdienen würde und wir haben
die Entschlossenheit weitere
Beitrittskandidaten gesehen sich zu
verlieren
erst jetzt für uns an der Zeit dieser
Entschlossenheit gerecht zu werden das
heißt dass wir uns darüber Gedanken
machen müssen wie wir uns auf jeden Fall
endete Union vorbereiten können wir
müssen die auch in den
schwarz-weiß-diskussionen über den
weiteren hinter uns lassen es geht ja
nicht darum ob wir entweder dazu und
vertiefen oder die Union gehen
beides tun damit wir wir politisch an
Gewichten
mit einer politischen Politik von einem
Jahr gelangten von kurze und Stahl
wirtschaftlichen Integration und nach
dem Fall des Einzelnen verwandelten wir
ein Wirtschaftsprojekt in eine wahre
Union der Menschen und
[Musik]
staatenment macht
ein Katalysator für den Fortschritte
25 von uns haben mit dem Aufbau einer
gesundheits-staaten sowie Enden werden
mit dem Aufbau von winds
verteidigungs-kommen wenn wir an einem
Strang ziehen und ich glaube dass Europa
Team Europa mehr als 30 Stunden
funktioniert meine Damen und Herren
Abgeordnete ich weiß dass dieses Haus
das auch und das war natürlich
ein richtiger Motor für die europäische
Integration das war's im Laufe der
Jahrzehnte und das ist es heute erneut
Support
und alle jene die die
euphorieren wollen damit sie den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
europäischen Präsident und deine
Änderung der Verträge
erreichen dazu müssen praktische Frage
tun haben wie eine Union noch mehr als
30 Ländern in der Praxis funktionieren
wird und insbesondere darüber wie wir
Handlungsfähigkeit die gute Nachricht
lautet dass sich bei jeder Erweiterung
wir würden dadurch weniger effizient als
Irrtum ergeben hat
die letzten
Generation
geeinigt
Impfstoffe zu kaufen wir haben in
Rekordzeit Sanktionen
wirklich aber wir müssen uns allen
anschauen und sehen wie sich eine
größere Union darauf auswirken würde
die Kommission eine Reihe von
Überprüfungen
umzusehen wie die einzelnen Bereichen
möglicherweise in eine größere Union
angepasst werden müssen wir werden uns
überlegen müssen wir unsere
Institutionen interessieren
würden wir müssen über die Zukunft
unseres Haushalt sprechen darüber was
daraus bezahlt wird und wieder aus sein
finanziert wird
wir müssen uns beide klar werden eine
Welt
die Abschreckung mehr den Weg zählt
Sicherheit garantieren können wir uns
heute stellen müssen
zu sein und die Kommission
deshalb werden unsere Unternehmen in die
Gespräche der Staats- und
Regierungsspitze unter belgischen
ratsvorsitze Berlin bringen uns treibt
Überzeugung dass die Vollendung der
Union das beste Investition in Frieden
die Sicherheit und den Wohlstand unseres
ist
die Zeit für Europa ist gekommen
zu denken und das Schicksal in die
eigene Hände zu nehmen
meine Damen und Herren Abgeordneter
Pflicht ist eine neue Geschichte für
Europa zu schreiben dies ist Dance today
hier steht Europa heute at the time in
einer Zeit und an einem Ort wo
Geschichte geschrieben wird future war
Kontinente die Zukunft unseres Kontinent
hängt von unseren häuslichen
Entscheidungen von den Schritten
die Menschen in Europa wünschen sich
eine Union die in einer Zeit des
Wettlaufs die Großmächte für sie
einstehen
zur Seite steht und wir werden
Europäerinnen und Europäern wichtig ist
ganz wichtig für Europa
einer jungen Generation zurück mit der
ich meine Rede bekommen habe dies ist
der Moment um ihre zu zeigen dass wir
ein Kontinent gestalten können
[Musik]
wenn sie wollen
mit der Natur versöhnt und bei der
Entwicklung neuer Technologien führend
ist ein Kontinent wieder mit Freiheit
und Frieden beeint ist wieder einmal
gilt momentan ganz Europa der Moment
sich seinem historischen Auftrag zu
stellen das Leben
[Applaus]
wir beginnen
Madame president of European Parlament
mit einem Präsident European Commission
Spanish Präsident sie dir
in spanischer vorsitzwert Corporation
[Musik]